hello rejects its Greg Alva here and
it's John here we're finally gonna do a
reaction review for the Iron Fist NYCC
trailer but before we do that we want to
give a shout out to today's video
sponsor audible.com now I don't know
about you guys but we hear the real
rejects we sure do love a good book but
being so busy it's hard to get all the
reading in that you sometimes want to
and that's where all of all calm comes
in audible has a huge selection of
audiobooks as well as news comedy and
original content all available in audio
format for your listening pleasure so
you can take your reading on the go
me personally I find myself using
audible a lot when I'm cleaning the
apartment or going on walks
I started off listening to the power by
Rhonda Byrne it's the follow up to the
secret and now I'm listening to 21
irrefutable laws of leadership by John C
Maxwell me I do a lot of driving
throughout the week and audible is a
great way for me to keep up with my
reading through the magic of listening
lately I've been revisiting Kurt
Vonnegut's slaughterhouse-five which is
one of my very favorite books on taking
air Atanas mindfulness in plain English
is a book I've been looking at Chris
Hardwick's The Nerdist way there's
there's tons of stuff in my Q there now
you're probably wondering how can I
access this amazing service it's simple
Greg I know John just click that link in
the description box head over to
audible.com slash rejects and sign up
for a 30 day trial today if you knew
that audible will start you off with a
free audio book of your choosing their
selection is enormous and no matter who
you are what you're into there's
something for you on audible.com
audible.com slash rejects
alright guys iron fist I just finished
Luke Cage on Netflix that's why I went
holding off on this trailer even though
I know this is like a totally different
character but I know in the comics Luke
Cage and iron fist they eventually work
together Heroes for Hire Power Man and
Iron Fist so just for my own weird thing
I wanted to finish Luke Cage before I
ever saw this trailer
alright J Holmes you ready I'm so ready
for this
there it is because of who you are there
will always be forces gathering against
evil
disguised as a friend slipping past you
as a stranger they are everywhere
now she's back if you choose to continue
whereas you are know that you risk
everything
it's time a child touched by fire
destined to be a greatest warrior
whoa whoa whoa
you see things with drive all of the
thousands mind
Oh
until I missed what he said it at the
last second purpose based off all the
information of what we're seeing from
the trailer it's it's definitely taking
the same approach that the other shows
did take where this is an origin tale
told over this series of 12 episodes
because or 13 episodes I think it seems
like it's gonna start off right when
he's returning back to yours and we're
probably gonna get glimpses of him his
origin you know flashbacks dedicated a
Kunlun I would like for them to do an
origin of and have a specific episode
there's this one episode of Luke Cage I
thought was really well done where it's
the most of the episode about 90% of it
is all dedicated to who Luke 8 was
before he got to Harlem and how he got
his powers and I like seeing that whole
one episode just dedicated to that it
was like the fourth or fifth episode of
something like that and I would like to
see that done here as well and good but
something tells me they're probably
gonna like you know cut back and forth
with flashbacks throughout maybe the
first six or so episodes showing like
where he got his powers and how he got
trained and everything like that because
they're probably gonna have to balance
two different worlds and tones here and
one thing I really like about including
him as the final defender he'll probably
be the one who has the financial access
to things in this MCU Netflix series you
got Jessica Jones you got Matt Murdock
and you got Luke Cage or all three
they're not well-to-do Luke Cage
probably being the brokest of them all
none of them are well-to-do they all
have financial struggles and they tend
and they also seem to think more in
terms of real realism and I think
realistic about things having Danny Rand
in there with is a cool choice because
he's younger than them and he's
wealthier than all of them at the same
time though he has more spiritual
beliefs where like he gets happen to
energy ease all about focus harnessing
his Chi it's not like it was necessarily
a magical show but I think this lines up
perfectly like Marvel really knows what
they're doing with lining up perfectly
with the release of Doctor Strange which
is all about magic and then you got this
one which at the same time is like can
be considered in the realm of magic but
mystical it's mystical yeah but they
still have here they're gonna
incorporate
a lot of the Buddhist philosophies it's
really gonna explore like the martial
arts mentality because while daredevil
is someone who is a hardcore extreme
martial artist he doesn't really embody
the spiritual mental side of a martial
art as someone who like they're
portraying Danny ran to be like is like
the first shot we see of him he's just
meditating and believes more in those
mystical elements because in even
daredevil season 2 they include the hand
which is much more of a mystical side of
daredevil but even Matt Murdock has a
hard time really believing about what
they believe is something to even
possibly be true whereas I believe like
if Danny ran was witness to the hand he
could easily believe that to be
something true well there's a lot of
interesting opportunities it seems like
for this show what I like about Marvel
shows is they do mix in philosophies and
they do mix and things that are just
sort of allegorical to life I think this
show gives us a nice opportunity like
you brought up to explore you know the
way crime and and whatever villains
we're gonna see coming how that affects
you know the upper side of New York as
well as the lower side and how the two
interplay cuz I get the sense he's gonna
have to live between high-class and low
class and there's some interesting you
have to mind there I'm excited to hear
that they're gonna bring in some of
those Buddhist tenants and stuff like
that and to you know just use that as as
character developing wallpaper I think
is a really cool idea for this that that
makes me more excited actually than this
trailer did the one thing with this show
that wasn't becoming clear to me is what
is the genre splice that they're doing
with this one what's their style because
daredevil was like that if it was that
dark and gritty vigilante show and then
Jessica Jones was that private eye film
noir kind of show Luke Cage is like the
black exploitation gangster show The
Wire this one I want to see what kind of
show is this gonna be like from this
trailer it kind of reminded me of
something I'd see from like a CW show
not necessarily a bad thing it's just I
really love when Marvel does kind of
that genre splice and I want to see what
specific genre they kind of leaning
towards here as well well I hope they
hope that they bring in some some love
and homage for come food cinema because
it's my understanding that this
character was partly created in response
to
come food craze in the 70s to bring in
some of that style I think would be an
awesome way to distinctive ID this show
cuz that's the thing I didn't get a ton
of from this trail like I thought it
looked cool and it promised you know all
the things that you want it promised you
know the mysticism of the fist it
promised you know cool fights it
promised some gritty drama some of those
things you see but I didn't get a sense
for what the style is and what it's
really gonna feel like I just got the
sense like oh cool marble show what's
most exciting about this is he has
mastery of the spectrum of martial arts
and so I hope that they take advantage
of different fighting styles and give us
some incredible martial arts fights
because this is an opportunity to get
different choreography teams in people
with different expertise you know like
movies like the raid and stuff like that
are so popular like martial arts is kind
of coming back and this would be a cool
way to showcase so many different styles
and I hope that we get to see that yeah
what I want to see here with in terms of
the martial arts cuz daredevil really
brought martial arts fighting to a whole
new level in terms of just like a
television show because the martial arts
fight sequences are so [ __ ] awesome
but those are more in terms of something
along the line they're not exactly like
the rain but more along the lines of
something like that where it's like
martial arts mix with real great yeah
that's really cool an Iron Fist I'm sure
there will be some of that but because
of the kind of character he is the kind
of fighter he is and the kind of bill
and so probably put up against I would
like to see more of like the classic
kind of kung fu martial arts more like
there's a dance to the kind of fighting
that's going on here because the rhythm
and the flow and like what a crawler II
yeah yeah exactly I think you pronounced
a Kunlun I really hope they go all-out
with the dedication to his origin in
Kunlun and seeing all that stuff because
that to me is part of his most
interesting part of this whole origin
tale when he gets his Iron Fist power
and state he like fights like some
serpent dragon like thing I really want
to see how they do that I hope they show
that in the actual series because none
of the Marvel shows have done something
that spectacular yet and so I would like
them to see like commit to some cool
creature features a monster the kind of
thing I know it's challenging because
you would need more of a budget you
would need it to look really good
visually however there are shows that
have done some cool creature effects
that
I think they could pull it off and I
really hope that they provide that for
us because they you know you only see
like quick glimpses of his past like I
was in the snow he's young Marvel and
Netflix seem like they if anybody has
the means to make a high production
value show it's them his origin story is
does harken back to these sort of its
Eastern myths and stuff like that and to
be able to see that translated if they
really take advantage of some of those
fantastical mythical elements like that
could really set this show apart again
and and also you know fit like you said
before in with the sort of new phase
where we've got Doctor Strange and we're
incorporating more of the mystical in
the magical into the MCU I really hope
they get into that I hope they embrace
Eastern culture in general because it
seems like Marvel is not afraid to
embrace you know diversity you know
because Jessica Jones there's a lot of
ruminations and themes of the feminine
in that show and luke cage's
to my understanding is a very black show
even though Danny Rand is a white guy I
hope that they you know really take
advantage of I know they have a lot of
you know supporting Asian characters and
whatnot I really hope they take
advantage of that stuff you know of
Eastern culture I've been one of those
people who's been like slightly public
about how I feel that Asian actors Asian
American actors have not really been
getting the work and the credit they
deserve in this industry and getting you
know like can from roles that they
should have probably gotten or roles
that could have been capitalized on more
and I'm especially seeing this new Bruce
Lee movie trailers I know there is a big
petition we're like millions of people
sign up like they really wanted Iron
Fist to be played by an Asian American
actor which would have been cool and
people were very upset when they didn't
do it I'm not upset about it I'm half
I'm half asian I have a big support for
the Asian community on this I'm not
particularly upset about it only because
in the comics he's not Asian but it
still would have been it would have been
but it's it's less like it's very less
upsetting them some ancient wonder yeah
Scarlett Johansson ghost in the shell'
or something that to me is a choice
where I can still see why Marvel went
this route because it seems to me that
it is kind of an important aspect of his
character a white guy who comes from
Amer
in culture like from the you know from
New York City then he gets his whole
life changed when he gets introduced in
the Eastern culture right and I know
that man kind of explored that would
that man begins there there is some
similarity yeah the so it seems to be an
essence of his character not to be that
and plus you know we do get other in
Asian characters that are you know I
think we saw Colleen we wing in there
and she was a girl the Asian girl with a
sword and I'm excited to see what she
provides for the show my theory with how
this show is gonna play out the plot
description of his origin tale because
this is obviously gonna be the origin to
how he becomes the not necessarily how
we became iron fist like throughout a
whole season because he returns with the
powers of iron fencing this is gonna be
about how he became the superhero known
as iron fist in this story just like how
daredevil got known to be the devil in
Hell's Kitchen how Luke Cage got to be
known the the hero of Harlem this is
gonna be how he beginning to know the
you know the iron fist of New York City
my prediction is like cuz they have the
character Harold me come in there and
Harold me comes a guy who betrayed his
dad and and he's seeking revenge on
Harold when he first gets back to New
York
my feeling is a Harold Meachem will
probably die about six or seven episodes
and in the comics some ninja comes in
and kills Harold and then there's that
whole story there and I feel like it'll
take over halfway there and then be that
whole other story where we'll probably
have to include people like Colleen wing
and they're more there's probably gonna
be some like love relationship with
Harold's daughter joy as you've seen the
trailer and everyone talked about it
when like she first appeared in
daredevil Gow's returning in this yeah
it was a really cool character I love
how they utilized sort of the daredevil
show I hear she's a really big part of
the iron fist world I wonder if she's
gonna be a more predominant villain in
this specific series it would be cool if
they took her she's kind of like a side
antagonist and daredevil season 1 and 2
it would be cool if they like made her
like a primary villain in this one
because and this one thing I love about
the MCU shows is they give us very
definitive villains for all their shows
you know we got Wilson Fisk and
daredevil we got killgrave and Jessica
Jones and then we had cottonmouth and
Luke Cage and this one's not really
specific specifically setting it up
because I know that hits his original
goal is to kill Harold but you know he
has
no legs and he's just old guy now that's
that sort of last morality tale that a
hero needs to learn I think because a
lot of here like Batman has that
spider-man has that like and it's a big
thing for Daniel Rance character to not
kill him because you know it shows a big
side of his heart that learn the pity
yeah exactly exactly I don't need to
kill this man he is a he's an old man
with no Lippard enough s what I really
want to see to is him really running the
company want to see like him really
conducting business like what is the
business all I know is he has a business
I don't know anything about the business
a workplace drama what is the business
that he could possibly take over and
I'll have to really worry about being
iron fist like imagine the state like
he's got to save people from crime but
also there's a meeting in 20 minutes
what's he gonna do is he gonna do oh my
god this is a woman is a single mother
and he has to fire her because she's not
really pulling her weight she keeps
showing up late for work that's real
human drama yeah what if they have to
keep paying her cuz you can just never
get in there to do the meeting yeah I
mean like I'm worried I'm on four years
now he has to like take over the company
that's a lot of pressure
ya have hope you read up on their stock
reports on their finance on what their
work you know matter how much
preparation you do when developing your
spiritual aspect of yourself if you
don't know business you will not succeed
in America no Trump 2017 greatest
president of all time he already is my
favorite he's my favorite I love do you
want to see some new Hardcore Trump
supporters just keep watching this
channel okay know all about it
make America something I don't know Joss
Whedon's clearly in support for not
Trump so I'm not Trump either yeah yeah
so if the MCU is gonna take a stand I'll
take a stand against Trump I don't think
it heroes in the NZ would be Trump
support you'd be a great villain same
thing with how Nixon was the president
of Watchmen they should make you front
the presidency alright ladies and gents
if you're new to the channel subscribe
today become a reject this John is
reasons to Jerry on his Twitter and
Instagram handle
and he is the social media manager of
facebook.com slash house audible you're
a great listening site don't forget to
click audible.com slash rejects or you
can listen to so many comic books that
would be great right yeah just remove
all the junk there's not even plot
description or there's no character
movement described in the audible it's
just a dialogue so it's kind of
confusing I think that'd actually be
really funny just a guy who's like reads
the dialogue that goes oh and in this
picture he's like swinging